mardi à 18h15 sur Public
Sénat bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires c'est l'heure de
Parlement Hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité
politique et parlementaire avec Katia
guilder bonjour Katia bonjour Michel et
dans l'actualité pour ceux qui on doutai
encore le match Sarkozi Fillon est
définitivement lancé le premier obtient
un non lieu de la justice dans l'affaire
B en cour et voit donc le ciel se
dégager le second est à l'offensive dans
la presse l'ancien Premier ministre pr
la
rupture 6 mois de travail et 55 heur
d'audition à l'Assemblée la commission
d'enquête parlementaire a rendu ses
conclusion sur l'affaire kusac une
mascarade pour l'UMP qui existe qui
estime que beaucoup de questions sont
restées sans réponse le rapport sera
rendu public la semaine prochaine et
puis vous en rappelez certainement en
mai dernier sortait sur vos écrans le
film le pouvoir plongé dans les
coulisses de l'Élysée le DVD sort cette
semaine avec des bonus le plus de l'bdo
vous emmène à la découverte de ces
scènes inédites une are invité Roger
kucci bonjour ancien ministre sénateur
UMP des hautes scènes vice-président de
l'UMP et proche de Nicolas Sarkozi alors
avant de revoir la semaine politique
avec vous écoutez ce que pensent
certains de vos collègues ver baptime au
micro de Hugo Lenart et Rodolphe Perro
écoutez
sympathique
incisif et puis très présent
spontanément je dirais Sarkosiste
sarcosiste encore sarcosiste toujours
tenace fidèle travailleur dynamisme
intelligence et sens de l'humour j'ai
j'ai qu'une j'ai qu'une
connaissance visuel et auditive de lui
c'est déjà pas mal al auditive
visiblement sarzi jusqu'au
bout je sais pas jusqu'au bout de quoi
mais je enfin je quand on dit ça comme
ça on a l'impression vous savez qu'il y
a les ultras du temps de du retour de
Louis XI c'est pas du tout le problème
le problème c'est de savoir qu'est-ce
qui sera déterminant pour faire gagner
la droite et le centre en 2017 alors
c'est loin il faut du temps et il faut
rester extrêmement calme et s'occuper
d'abord des élections municipal et
cetera moi je considère qu'à terme
peut-être que je me trompe mais après
tout le débat est tout ouvert je
considère qu'à terme celui qui sera le
meilleur fédérateur de la droite et du
centre si nous voulons un candidat
unique aux élections présidentiel entre
d'un côté le Front National et de
l'autre côté François Hollande c'est
Nicolas Sarkozi qui peut le mieux le
plus rassembler dans ces conditions je
suis favorable au retour voilà c'est pas
c'est pas une espèceiste un jour çaiste
toujours c'est ça mais mais Sarkozy vous
savez je vais vous dire quelque chose de
de que que je le que je lui ai dit à
plusieurs reprises je peux pas dire que
j'ai été comment dire allez le plus gâté
le mieux traité sous le mandat précédent
par rapport à d'autres ministres qui
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement critiques
mais le problème c'est pas uniquement
mon sort personnel c'est pas uniquement
est-ce que j'ai été couvert d'or et
d'argent et de pouvoir et donc est-ce
que je lui dois tout c'est pas ça le
souci c'est de se dire est-ce que je
considère que mon camp politique a des
choses à dire a une vraie chance de
revenir et a une capacité à jouer
l'alternance et puis après on choisit
voilà Roger carucci je vais vous
proposer une petite image après on va
revenir sur toute l'actualité he c'était
votre première intervention dans un
hémicycle c'était en 2000 en mai 2000
très précisément vous avez été élu
sénateur en 99 vous voyez sur ces sur
ces images 13 ans après j'ai la même
tête ouais à part l'expérience qu'est-ce
qui a fondalentalement changé chez vous
mes costume
euh non qu'est-ce qui a changé en cas
euh qu'est-ce qui a changé forcément le
le travail parlementaire vous vous fait
acquérir de la maturité vous fait
acquérir des connaissances vous fait
acquérir pour moi en tout cas le respect
des autres c'est-à-dire que je l'avais
déjà pour être forme on a toujours
considéré que j'étais trop consensuel
trop aimable pas assez dur on dit
incisif oui mais jamais agressif je n'ai
jamais moi ni insulté les gens ni
considéré que l'injure était un élément
euh du débat public non je pense que
c'est plus de maturité plus de réflexion
sur la situation réelle du pays et puis
euh une espèce de sérénité peut-être la
sérénité des sénateurs en tout cas la
sérénité qui consiste à dire j'ai eu
beaucoup de fonctions pas les plus
élevées de la République et je n'y
prétends pas euh mais en même temps euh
une capacité d'analyse une capacité
d'organisation qui sont peut-être
reconnu et très utiles pour ceux que je
serviraiis allez Roger carotier on va
attaquer ce début de semaine on parle
évidemment de Nicolas Sarkozi mais pas
seulement l'ancien président de la
République a donc bénéficié d'un nonlieu
dans l'affaire bê encour et de son côté
l'ancien Premier ministre François
Fillon mène l'offensive dans les médias
à la une du Journal du Dimanche à la Une
de Valeurs Actuelles le tout résumé par
Germain Andr évidemment il va casser un
peu de vaisselle après son avertissement
dimanche dernier François Fillon met les
pieds dans le plat dans Valeurs
Actuelles un long entretien et surtout
une déclaration de guerre l'ancien
Premier ministre vise directement
Nicolas Sarkozi il estime être mieux
placé que lui pour l'emporter en 2017
pas question non plus de minorer l'échec
en mai 2012 quand on perd une élection
on doit se remettre en cause sinon c'est
un bras d'honneur au français des propos
en partie démentis par les fillonistes
mais la rupture est claire et assumer ce
sont pas des propos violents François
Fillon dit simplement qu'il se sent bien
placé pour la présidentielle 2017 il se
sent bien placé en tout cas pour la
primaire qui aura lieu il a bien le
droit de se sentir effectivement en
bonne position c'est son droit le plus
absolu je vois pas comment on peut lui
contester le fait que les sondages lui
donnant effectivement cette position il
puisse lui reconnaître qu'il est bien
placé lui aussi en tête dans les
sondages Alain Jupé a lancé sur son bloc
un nouveau signal d'alerte si la guerre
des chefs continue c'est l'existence
même de l'UMP qui est menacée si on
continue ainsi à tirer dans tous les
sens c'est plus de la vaisselle cassée
c'est des éléphants dans un magasin de
de porcelaine et à terme oui je pense
que ça pourrait nous mener à
l'éclatement de de l'UMP 2017 c'est une
chose mais si on est tous morts avant ça
ne donnera rien en 2015 il y aura
beaucoup de choses mais on aura fini les
élections et que s'il y a un débat un
combat qui se mène il est tout à fait
normal que quelqu'un qui se présente dis
je suis le meilleur si sil dit pas ça il
se présente pas pour le moment seul
Xavier Bertrand et François Fillon sont
officiellement candidats à cette
primaire ouverte de l'UMP prévue en 2016
alors Roger carucci comment
appréciez-vous ces mots ce nouveau
positionnement de François Fillon qui
s'estime mieux placé que les autres pour
2017 mieux placé que qui pour le moment
ah oui non bah la matière bien sûr que
non
euh les sondages d'ailleurs sont là
qu'est-ce vouz que je vous dise on dit
par exemple ah là là regardez ce sondage
qui est pas très bon pour Nicolas
Sarkozi il y a 54 % des Français qui
disent qu'il ne regrettent pas que
Nicolas Sarkozi ne soit plus là sauf que
54 % des Français mais 94 % des
sympathisants de l'UMP regrettent 94 %
des sympathisants de l'UMP on peut pas
dire que dans l'électorat UMP qui est
quand même le fondement le noyau au bris
au premier tour on peut pas dire qu'il y
a un désamour à l'égard de Nicolas
Sarkozi d'ailleurs quand vous faites des
sondages sur les sympathisants de l'UMP
Nicolas Sarkozi est toujours donné loin
devant c'est un plébicide pour Nicolas
Sarkozi ça veut dire quoi je auss très
simplement est-ce que si Nicolas Sarkozi
décide de revenir il sera oigé obligé de
passer par des primaires attendez
attendez d'abord moi je ne sais pas si
Nicolas Sarkozi décidera de r dire je
milite pour mais c'est lui qui décidera
si les conditions politiques sont
remplies un élément personnel c'est
aussi dans son analyse est-ce que la
gauche conduit à la catastrophe est-ce
que la droite est en état de gagner
est-ce que on a besoin de si on a besoin
de lui il faudra bien qu'à un moment il
décide voilà alors ensuite il est il est
le pour moi le fédérateur naturel de la
droite et du centre il est dans les
sondages sur oui pourquoi oui ben
pourquoi d'abord parce que il a déjà
gagné une présidentielle il l' perdu
aussi oui c'est vrai de peu et et on
était tous avec lui compris François
Fillon quand j'entends François Fillon
dire aujourd'hui
rupture quand vous avez été 5 ans le
Premier ministre d'un président de la
République dire moi je voudrais un
projet de rupture mais de rupture donc
par rapport à la politique qu'il a
lui-même conduit c'est ce qu'avait
employé Nicolas Sarkozi à l' de Jair
nétait pas Premier ministre de Jacques
Chirac il avait été ministre c'est vrai
mais il était en rupture sur une période
longue je je dis pas attendez hein si
Nicolas Sarkozi disait pour des raisons
multiples je ne reviens
pas je François Fillon serait un des
mieux placés incontestablement donc il a
raison de jouer sa carte et sa chance
puisque comme on ne sait pas si Nicolas
Sarkozi revient bah forcément François
Fillon doit s'affirmer et avoir une
identité mais il est dans une position
compliquée pour lui qu'est-ce qui
pourrait empêcher son retour aujourd'hui
de Nicolas Sarkozi Nicolas Sarkozi
lui-même c'est-à-dire que je pense que
c'est pas les bisbilles qu'on essaye
maladroitement d'ailleurs de de mettre
en avant pour dire a et cararassie et
Machin ou d'accord bon très bien on a
compris on a vu pour l'affaire B en
cours et maintenant le nonlieu donc
c'est pas ça c'est est-ce
que ayant beaucoup donné ministre de
l'Intérieur ministre de l'Économie
président de la république ayant mené le
combat a a été battu même si c'est de
peu est-ce que il considèr qu'il est
indispensable qu'il revienne pour
assurer l'alternance s'il pense que
quelqu'un peut le faire mieux et gagner
il se dira pourquoi revenir l'instant
parmi les candidats possibles il y a
aussi François Fillon il y a aussi
Nicolas Sarkozy si jamais il ne venait
pas il ne souhaitait pas en tout cas y
aller il y aurait aussi d'autres
personnes comme Al j Bertrand Xavier
Bertrand l'a déjà dit qu'il était
candidat Alain Jupé il doit se dire
après tout s'il faut quelqu'un qui
apaise quelqu'un qui est un peu
au-dessus pourquoi pas et d'ailleurs
entre nous soit dit c'est un homme
d'État de très grande qualité donc
pourquoi pas Jean-François Copé sera
probablement également tenté par la
primaire ouverte si Nicolas Sarkozi ne
revenait pas lui a dit très clairement
si Nicolas Sarkozi revient je serai avec
lui donc si Nicolas Sarkozi revenait
Copé ne serait pas candidat au prima il
soutiendrait Nicolas Sarkozi mais si
Nicolas Sarkozi ne revient pas Copé a
toute sa place dans la primaire ouverte
et puis bah à ce moment-là les choses se
feront si Nicolas Sarkozi ne revient pas
il y aura des reclassements et en sens
inverse si Nicolas Sarkozi annoncé son
retour bien des gens qui aujourd'hui
disent je suis pour un tel ou un tel se
reclasserait derrière Nicolas
Sarkozi alors on poursuit avec mardi et
ce coup d'éclat à l'Assemblée nationale
ah
oui les députés UMP claque la porte de
la commission d'enquête sur l'affaire
Cusak il boycotte la remise du rapport
et organise un point presse quelques
heures plus tôt pour dire leur colère
pour l'UMP les questions qui dérangent
ont été tout simplement évacué du
rapport Marion Lefèvre Valérie Brochard
l'image est inédite Christian Jacob
entouré par tous les membres UMP de la
commission d'enquête sur l'affaire
Cahusac à quelques heures de l'adoption
du rapport il tente un coup d'éclat nous
avons décidé au groupe UMP de ne pas
cautionner cette mascarade on est
véritablement dans dans un mode de
fonctionnement qui qui a aibl pour ne
pas dire qui humilie le Parlement
mascarade le mot est lancé il va
raisonner toute la journée dans les
couloirs de l'Assemblée l'opposition
rejette en bloc les conclusions du
rapport et puisque la commission
d'enquête n'a pas pu auditionner le
Premier ministre les députés UMP ont
décidé de l'interpeller dans l'hémicycle
Monsieur le Premier Ministre une
question résume toutes les autres
avez-vous oui ou non participé à une
réunion le 16 janvier à l'Élysée en
présence de François Hollande et de
Jérôme Cahusac pour idé de l'enquête
administrative qui devait blanchir ce
dernier en brisant la muraille de Chine
cette affaire a commencé par un parjure
éviter qu'aujourd'hui elle ne s'agève
devant l'Assemblée nationale par un
autre parjure la parole est à Monsieur
Alain Vidal jean-mar refuse de répondre
c'est précisément cette impossibilité
d'interroger le chef du gouvernement qui
divise les députés de la commission que
savait le Premier ministre et le
président de la République du compte en
Suisse de Jérôme Cahusac alors là nous
avons une divergence avec le
rapporteur nous notre thèse c'est que
alors que le président disposait de la
République disposait dès le mois de
décembre 2012ination mettant en doute
les affirmations répétées d'innocence de
Jérôme Cahusac et bien le président n'a
pas mis fin à ses fonctions
ministérielles car il faut pas inverser
les choses qui détenait la preuve
c'était pas les membres du gouvernement
ou l'état le président est le rapporteur
de la commission d'enquête ne sont pas
d'accord sur les responsabilités de
l'appareil d'État ni l'UMP ni l'UDI ni
les vers n'ont adopté le rapport qui
sera rendu public le 15 octobre prochain
alors Roger kou il y a eu beaucoup de
tumulte au sujet de de ce rapport mais
quel peut-être vraiment le le rôle d'une
commission d'enquête quand quand la
justice enquête en même temps sur la
même affaire c'est c'est toujours le
problème euh on essaie d'éviter
d'ailleurs la création de commission
d'enquête lorsque la justice enquête
déjà parce que on sait que à plusieurs
reprises la réponse des autorités ou des
gens convoqués c'est de dire secret de
l'astructure je peux pas donc
euh il y a des limites à à la commission
d'enquête dans cette affaire je sais pas
si c'est l'enquête judiciaire qui a
beaucoup gêné aou si c'est le fait que
l'appareil d'État n'a pas voulu
totalement répondre cette réunion dont
on parle au mois de janvier avec
François Hollande elle a pas été
découverte pardon de dire dans le Canard
Enchaîné ou dans je sais pas quoi c'est
Monsieur Moscovici qui dit devant la
commission il y a eu une réunion dans le
bureau du président de la République
avec le Premier ministre donc le travail
de cette commission n'a pas été bien
fait non si mais moi j'aurais trouvé
normal que le premier ministre aille
s'expliquer dire voilà comment ça s'est
passé voilà pourquoi et cetera si vous
voulez le le refus de répondre la
manière dont Monsieur boscovici c'est
quand même beaucoup mais de là quand
même Boé la remise du rapport pour les
députés um vous avez pas dire que ça
donne une bonne image du du Parlement
tout ça je sais pas si c'est une bonne
image du Parlement ou si ce sont les
limites de des commissions d'enquête
parce que ça veut quand même dire que
lorsque euh les autorités de l'État
refusent de répondre le Parlement est
assez euh il a fallu peut-être attendre
un tout petit peu quitte à revoir la
formulation de cette demande comêre
qu'il fallut que on laisse faire d'abord
la justice et qu'ensuite on on est une
analyse plus politique mais le débat
politique est là la vérité c'est que bon
c'est pas la PE nous se faire un dessin
très
probablement les plus hautes autorités
de l'État avaient des doutes à défaut de
certitude avait au moins des doutes sur
les comptes de Monsieur kayusac est-ce
qu'ils auraient dû plus tôt prendre des
décisions probablement oui on change de
sujet RER carucci nous sommes toujours
mardi direction forback en Mosel pour
Manuel Vals le ministre de l'Intérieur
part dans une tournée qu'on va qualifier
d'antifront national kamamya
compampusan petite balade au marché qu
quelques poignées de main manuel Vals
s'invite à forbacosel première étape
d'un tour de France le rôle d'un
ministre de l'Intérieur le rôle de
l'état des forces de l'ordre c'est de
s'attaquer à la délinquence à
l'insécurité cambriolage à la violence
aux incivilités bref à ce qui gênne
pourr la vie des gens et notamment dans
des territoires où il y a beaucoup de
gens modestes qui souffre déjà de la
crise derrière le discours officiel une
visite stratégique selon le front
for c'est le terrain de Flori Filippo
c'est ici que le numéro 2 du FN se
présente au municipal il fait même une
tournée j'ai cru comprendre Antin
électorale sur les fonds du ministère de
l'Intérieur au passage pour soutenir un
parti socialiste en mode panique en
pleine affolement parce qu'il voit la
dégringolade et il voit la dynamique
très très forte sur le terrain notamment
à forb du Front national du
rassemblement blarine et de ma
candidature une tournée antifn
l'entourage du ministre de l'Intérieur
dé mais au Sénat du de l'UMP le
parallèle avec les résultats du parti
d'extrême droite à brigol est vite
établi il y a déjà comme une forme
d'affolement enfin une petite élection
cantonn à à brignoolle mobilise le
gouvernement le Premier ministre en tête
et un pleoton de ministre va aller
maintenant à la rencontre des population
pour dire mais non mais non
rendormez-vous bonne gens tout ça
n'existe pas je pense que d'abord c'est
une politique à courte vue et
deuxièmement encore une fois ce n'est
pas de communication dont les Français
ont besoin ils ont besoin de résultats
des critiques qui ne freinent pas Val
fort de son bon score dans les sondages
d'opinion il compte se rendre à Calais
notamment pour parler cette fois
immigration VO cette visite de Manuel
vas a donc eu lieu après le scrutin de
brigol on va s'arrêter sur cette percée
du FN un scrutin marqué aussi par un
fort taux d'abstention c'est le zoom de
l'bdo Roland kérol est avec nous pour
l'analyse bonjour Roland Kol vous êtes
Pol log consultant pour les chaînes
parlementaires ce scrutin pour vous
a-t-il une résonance nationale ou
faut-il au contraire le voir à l'échelle
local à brigol dans le Sud-Est où le FN
a déjà fait de de bons scores depuis de
de longues années depuis deux République
et depuis donc des décennies les gens
qui commentent les élections partielles
disent régulièrement des satises et et
ça fait partie des lois du genre donc
évidemment une élection partielle et
surtout une cantonale partielle ça n'est
qu'une cantonnale partielle pensez dans
ce canton de Brignol on a déjà voté deux
fois en 2011-22 on a été annulé deux
fois on est chaque fois près de 50 50 et
dans chaque fois c'est le Front National
qui fait soit 49 soit 51 le voilà à 40
dans un premier tour et ça fait trembler
la France alors voilà ça n'est que ça
c'est l'un des cantons où le Front
National est le plus fort en France il
confirme ça la nouveauté mais c'est pas
non plus une nouveauté dans les partiels
c'est que le le Parti socialiste les
partis de la majorité parlementaire sont
désavoués puisqu'ils sont ça fait
maintenant une habitude plus là au
second tour mais il y a pas de Percé du
Front national il y a beaucoup
d'abstention il y a eu beaucoup
d'abstention dans classique dans une
partielle il y a de tiers d'abstention
comme c'est la loi donc avec Roger
carucci Roland kerol vous êtes d'accord
pour dire qu'il n'y a pas de signal en
vue des élections municipales on peut
pas tirer de conclusion de tout ça si en
même temps il y a des signaux mais les
signaux pour le moment sont plutôt dans
les sondages les Français une fraction
des Français près d'un cas des Français
sont tentés de dire alors on ne sait pas
si c'est j'ai décidé d'aller voter Front
national ou si c'est attention jeis
attention je suis prêt à le faire si
vous ne me Satis faz pas voilà on ne
sait pas encore ça n'est qu'une
déclaration de sondage mais on n pas
pour le moment dans les urnes dans les
faits ni dans les adhésions au parti
Front national on n' pas de preuve quand
j'ai entendu que c'était le premier
parti de France il faut tout de même pas
exagérer à part pour les élections
européennes mais le problème c'est que
vous savez dans une période où les gens
sont accablés d'impôt très critiques sur
l'insécurité sur l'identité euh ils
savent plus où ils vont il y a cette
espèce de ralbol et on dit bah je peux
voter Front national est-ce que pour
autant au municipal avec des listes avec
des candidats soit sortants soit pas
sortants mais qu'ils connaissent est-ce
que la réaction est la même bien sûr que
non donc je pense qu'en réalité euh il
il va y avoir un Tami les municipales
c'est un vrai Tami et il y aura pas de
Percé du Front National au municipal
est-ce que vous estimez qu'on en fait
trop autour de Marine Le Pen bien sûr
pourquoi qui à qui la faute Comédia ou
politique non tout le monde tout le
monde le gouvernement qui multiplie les
textes droit de vote des
étrangers suppression des taxes sur les
visas mesures en faveur de telle ou
telle catégorie le gouvernement pousse
parce qu'il se dit ah si ça pouvait
affaiblir l'opposition parementaire
l'opposition parlementaire en parle trop
et les médias aussi donc toujours le jeu
de l'instrumentalisation du Fond
national que ce soit simplement une
instrumentalisation je crois qu'il y a
une vraie un vrai effet de mode que les
médias donnent le là et qu'on est dans
un moment où il fait beau et on dit ah
c'est bon pour le Front national il
pleut c'est bon pour le Front national
il y a il y a une espèce de mode qui
s'est installée d'une montée
irrésistible du Front National et je
pense que ça risque de finir par
paraître vrai parce que c'est au fond
qu'il faut répondre aux gens et pas à
l'effet de mode alors justement vous
montez sur quoi au front pour pour
répondre à pas vous sur quoi
vousiste très déterminé et en même
temps j'ai évolué je le reconnais avec
la situation et la droit décomplexé
comme dirait COP Ctait pas forcément au
départ ma tasse de thé moi j'étais
beaucoup plus sur des consensus et tout
mais je crois que il faut dire les
choses ce que ne supporte plus en
période de crise les gens c'est l'espèce
de dissimulation des vrais sujets les
vrais sujets c'est la délinquence les
vrais sujets c'est que l'immigration
clandestine a explosé et qu'on n peut
plus les vrais sujets c'est que
l'explosion fiscale ne peut plus être
maîtrisé comme ça donc la baisse des
dépenses publiques un meilleur contrôle
de l'immigration la remise en cause de
Schengen le fait de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de la me l'aide médicale pour
les les les les sans-papiers
tous ces sujetsl il faut les traiter de
manière républicaine il s'agit pas
d'avoir des solutions excessives mais il
faut arrêter de dire non non on parle
surtout pas de ça parce que si on parle
de ça ça fait monter le frontc National
à force de dire ça on parle de rien et
comme on parle de rien les gens disaient
ben puisqu'il nous parle de rien on va
vers les extrêmes dernier mot sur le
front national c'est Thierry Mondon le
porte-parole du groupe PS qui l'a dit
aujourd'hui je voudrais juste que vous
l'écoutiez je voudrais juste que vous
l'écoutiez on va réagir juste après le
Front National est ou pas un parti
d'extrême droite je pense que non
seulement c'est un parti d'extrême
droite mais que c'est même plus que ça
c'est un Parti national fasciste ceux et
celles ceux et celles d'entre vous qui
en douteraient liront avec un grand
intérêt le discours de Marine Le Pen en
clôture de l'université d'été de
Marseille Carol le FN un parti d'extrême
droite ou pas je crois que les les
sympathisants eux-mêmes du Front
national lorsqu'ils choisissent sur une
celle gauche droite chez les sondeurs
l'endroit où ils sont ils se mettent le
plus à droite de la droite possible donc
extrême droite ça me paraît une
catégorisation pour un politologue qui
n'a rien de scandaleux ils sont les
héritiers de cette tradition ils
occupent cette place sur les chiquers
politiques évidemment quand j'entends en
revente national national fasciste on ne
voit pas ni dans les méthodes ni dans le
programme actuel du Front national ce
qui pourrait dire ça populiste sûrement
il y a une espèce de volonté de flatter
le peuple dans ses insttins he de pas
participer à l'éducation civique à
laquelle sont dans lequel sont tous les
partis politiques oui national
fascisteid professeur d'histoire moi
nation ça me choque parce que ça
rappelle enfin on imagine les cohortes
de
sa dans les villes et on imagine tout ce
qu'on veut autour de de la période nazi
faut pas tout mélanger d'abord parce que
ça discrédite le propos que l'on tient
si on est excessif les gens dis oui
d'accord ça va ça suffit donc
non pense je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt un parti populiste qui pour
préparer sa mu future essaye de se
dédiaboliser y compris par rapport à
l'extrême droite c'estàdire que Marine
leupen qui espère un jour quand même
contrairement à son père qui espère un
jour accéder au pouvoir essae de
préparer les étapes de command devenir
un parti entre guillemets plus
acceptable par le fameux arc républicain
donc tout va y être elle va même refuser
extrême droite elle refusera populiste
elle va dire qu'elle a des voix de
gauche et de droite voilà
donc notre combat est plus sur la
caricature des propositions que sur le
classement parce que ça n'a pas de sens
alors on va changer de de sujet on va
passer à mercredi avec un texte très
controversé la réforme pénale a été
présentée en conseil des ministre le
projet de loi de Christian tobra
contient une mesure phare pour lutter
contre la récidive la peine en milieu
ouvert autrement dit la prison à la
maison un projet fustigé par la droite
explication déterminé et imperturbable
Christian tobira défend son projet pénal
pour désengorger les prisons et lutter
contre la récidive sa mesure phare la
création d'une peine de probation
alternative à l'emprisonnement elle sera
effectuée en milieu ouvert sous
surveillance étroite seul les délit
Passi de 5 ans de prison maximum sont
concernés les crimes en sont donc exclus
au cœur de la réforme le conseiller de
probation le Premier ministre a annoncé
la création d'un millier d'emplois je
rappelle que un millier d'emplois c'est
quand même une augmentation de 30 % du
corps un millier d'emploi qui va
concerner bien entendu les conseillers
d'insertion et de probation mais
également parce que pour que ça
fonctionne il faut des personnels
administratif et technique donc
également des personnels administratifs
et techniques le projet de loi prévoit
aussi la suppression des peines planché
ces peines minimales et automatiques
emblématique du quinquena de Nicolas
Sarkozi dévoilé cet été la réforme est
très controversée objet d'un bras de fer
estival entre Christian tobira et son
collègue manuel Vals en désaccord sur le
fond et fustigé par la droite qui y voit
un feu vert donné au délinquants cette
réforme pénale elle est complètement
hors sol complètement hors sol tient pas
compte des victimes contrairement à ce
qui a été dit le texte de loi sera battu
après les élections municipales
officiellement pour cause de calendrier
chargé à l'Assemblée en attendant la
ministre poursuit son tour de France
pour expliquer et défendre sa réforme
voilà donc elle n'est toujours pas
eu non c'est gresque je veux dire ce
texte était la priorité des priorités on
devait l'avoir dès octobre novembre puis
hop on se dit oh là là entre Vals tobira
il v se fiche sur la tête devant tous
les parlementaires après les
municipales texte ah Vals Val ball
urir de faire pas seulement de parler
parce que ça on disait tout à l'heure
quels sont les textes les mesures et
tout pour faire monter le F enfin quand
vous dites aux gens dans les cités
difficiles moi j'ai été élu à n Il a
Villeneuve la Garen avec des cités
difficiles quand vous leur dites alors
tous ceux qui sont condamnés à moins de
5 ans ferme ils sont dehors sincèrement
les policiers
qui plus où le fait de sortir un
dealer du secteur de de la capacité
d'être là c'est déjà dans l'exemple
donné aux autres dans la sanction qui
est affichée une mesure qui est bonne
pour tout le monde et pour la vie des
gens des gens modestes pas des gens qui
dans leurs hôtels particuliers hein dans
les beaux quartiers voit pas souvent les
dealers moi je je suis atéré de voir ça
mais en réalité on avait deux politiques
soit on construisait des places de
prison ce que nous voulions faire ce que
Manuel elle va s demander et puis c'est
non c'est C deux visions de la société
deux idéologies qui qui s'affrontent
finalement non pourquoi pas du tout moi
je je considère pas être sécuritaire fou
mais que des gens ayant vraiment
commisid parce que pour aller à 5 ens
ferme au jour d'aujourd'hui il faut pas
juste avoir volé une pomme hein il faut
pas exagérer argument Christian tira qui
dit que ça ça
fa
maim attz je parle pas des peines
prévues par le code quivent très très
lourdes mais qui ne sont pas ou jamais
atteint à ce niveaul par les jugements
les jugement pour arriver à 5 ans ferme
c'est que vous avez fait vraiment bon
moi je trouve que c'est excessif dans
une société
fragilisée avec des gens inquiets avec
la multiplication des actes de
délinquence l'insécurité dans les
transports dans la rue les gens ont peur
peur je dis pas qu'il sortent à dans la
rue oui ça y est ils ont un calachnikof
à la main mais il y a une inquiétude et
ben c'est un mauvais signal voilà c'est
un mauvais signal construisons des place
de prison humanisons les prisons faisons
en sorte de mieux réinsérer très bien
faisons de la prévention parfait mais ne
jetez pas en pâure allez on va vous les
remettre tous dehors et puis vous vous
débrouillerez dans la vie des quartiers
B carotier je vous propose de retourner
vers l'Assemblée nationale vous avez
déjà vous avez sûrement entendu de belle
sur les banques que ce soit au Sénat ou
à l'Assemblée quand vous étiez ministre
en charge des relations avec le
Parlement est-ce qu'on vous a déjà fait
le coup de la poule de la poule non j'ai
eu parfois pire mais bon donc c'est
limitation sur les sur les bancs
évidemment vous l'avez entendu d'un élu
UMP qui a imité le cactage d'une poule
pendant l'intervention d'une élu
écologiste Véronique massonau écoutez je
ne le ni pas mais il est nécessaire de
voir au-delà de ce critère l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé notamment oh ça
suffit là mais qui c'est qui s'est fait
ça enfin arrêtez quoi je suis pas une
poule hein c'est bon il y a des
comportements la durée moyenne de
cotisation est de 35 ans pour les femmes
alors l'élu concerné à écopé de de
sanction financières pour un mois pour
vous c'est du matchisme ou c'est de la
bêtise comment vous qualifiz ce genre de
comportement moi je vais vous dire euh
lorsque j'étais au gouvernement chargé
des relations avec le Parlement j'avais
eu des
entretiens avec Jean-Marc herraud à
l'époque président du groupe socialiste
et avec d'autres d'ailleurs pour
dire franchement l'image donnée par la
assemblée plus pardon je dis pas ça
parce que je suis sénateur plus par
l'assemblée que par le Sénat ù les
séances de questions peuvent être un peu
brutales mais pas à ce point mais euh
l'image est pas bonne enfin je veux dire
l'opinion publique se dit qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce carnaval on est dans la
crise on est tous en train de dire
quelles sont les solutions pour l'emploi
et tout c'est il voit ça cette espèce de
spectacle souvent affligeant où les gens
s'insultent où les gens se méprisent on
peut faire de la poliqueque mais oui
mais parce que j'allais presque dire il
faut que dans chaque groupe politique
que dans chaque parti politique les gens
disent attendez vous pouvez vous opposer
fermement à vos adversaires politiques
ne pas d'insulte pas d'injure pas de
mépris ouvert pas de cris déplacé on
fait ça parce que ah il faut passer à la
télé ah est-ce qu'on m'a vu ah est-ce
que je et et je trouve ça désolant pour
la démocratie
vous monde parce que là gauche droite
sincèrement vous avez des héros du 15h
là qui qui se reconnaîtront parce que ou
mais non mais c'est c'est et qui arrivve
et qui se disent vous allez voir je vais
faire le spectacle pour qu'on me voit à
défaut d'idées hurlon et ben je trouve
ça affligeant je pense qu'on peut dire
prenez des mesures beaucoup plus fortes
pourqu simplement Enes sont prévu je
suis désolé de vous le dire le règlement
intérieur de l'Assemblée comme le
règlement intérieur du Sénat prévoit des
mesures mes progressives qui sont fortes
sauf que c'est au président d' décider
vous savez on ferait quelques exemples
ça
s'arrêterait alors on va passer à jeudi
on va parler des retraites avec là
encore un peu de cacophonie dans le
vote erreur ou acte manqué un des
articles clés de la réforme des
retraites a été purement supprimé h
députés socialistes ont voté contre
l'article 4 qui visait à décaler la date
de revalorisation des pensions au 1er
octobre une erreur de vote rectifiée
mais qui a suffit à semer le désordre
dans l'hémicycle RIM bamur coup de
théâtre à l'Assemblée mercredi soir à la
surprise générale à 44 voix contre 39
les députés suppriment le report de 6
mois de la revalorisation annuelle des
retraites c'était l'un des articles les
plus controversés du projet de loi
problème il s'agirait d'une simple
erreur de vote de certains députés
socialistes au total d'entre eux
affirment C
AZ demand j'ai le sentiment que le
résultat du vote hier soir est une
trahison du réel vote que j'ai voulu
effectuer et que j'ai fait corriger hier
et dès l'ouverture la séance ne bruisse
que de cette erreur Marisol Touren
demande le revote de cet article il y a
donc eu une erreur qui va être réparé le
gouvernement demandera qu'il y ait une
nouvelle délibération sur cet article ce
qui se fait de façon très classique mais
à l'évidence la droite cherche à
instrumentaliser ce qui s'est passé à
transformer un incident technique en
difficulté politique elle a choisi une
tactique de l'obstruction la décision
passe très mal auprès des autres groupes
aujourd'hui dire qu'il s'agit d'une
erreur de manipulation dire que H voix
socialiste c'est-à-dire même avec le
couplage que quatre députés a pu se
tromper je dis que c'est véritablement
un dessin donner un dénis au vote des
parlementaires cette nuit pour continuer
à vouloir massacrer les les les
retraités et baisser leurs pension c'est
vraiment de l'acharnement madame la
ministre et ici vous espérez arriver à
tordre le bras des collègues qui ont
voté avec nous hier qui d'ailleurs ce
matin ne sont pas là peut-être qu'ils
ont été assignés à résidence les députés
continuent les discussions autour de la
création du compte pénibilité dans une
ambiance qui s'annonce
tendueussi ça vous est arrivé aussi
quand vous étiez eu des erreurs de vote
alors incident ou acte manqué quand on
quand on fait une erreur de vot
si vous en avez un ou deux il peut y
avoir des erreurs de vote
euh h surtout h sur pas grand monde hein
c'est pas
là c'est l'acte manqué c'est-à-dire
qu'en réalité euh ils ont été dans le
débat convaincu qu'il fallait pas voter
une mesure extrêmement négative pour les
retraiter ils sont dit moi dans ma circo
je vais me faire engueuler si je vote
une mesure où je dis au retraité on va
prlever sur vous et on dit al Mo votre
compte je veux pas de ça puis le
lendemain comme le parti le gouvernement
vous êtes tombé sur la tête en disant
ouais inadmissible regarde dans quelle
situation tu nous mets on s'en sort
comme on peut en disant ben j'ai
peut-être pas bien vu ce que j'ai fait
mais c'est pas moi parce que peut-être
que j'avais donné procuration mais bon
enfin d'accord en tout cas c'est un
acteementé alors la deuxème délibération
est de droit donc ça la ministre a
raison sur le fond mais s dit long sur
le fait que le groupe socialiste va dans
ce débat sur rraite va voter ce texte
avec vraiment si on pouvait avoir des
boulets sur les pieds et si on pouvait
ne pas le faire vous pourriez pas le
faire par décret sans nous ce serait
mieux sur le fond quand même il y a des
avancées il y a la création de sur la
création de ce compte
pénibilitéibilité tout monde par depuis
des années on a voul le faire aussi
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
c'est quand même un progrès par rapport
à la précédente réforme de 201 vous
plaentez ils n'ont rien fait du tout
c'est c'est une fausse réforme c'est une
non réforme on vous dire ah bah oh là là
on va passer à 43 ans mais alors dans 15
ans euh pour le reste on touche pas à à
l'âge légal de la retraite ce qui est
quand même l'élément le plus lourd en
vrai dans la dans une
réforme si on veut équilibrer les
comptes on y peut rien et c'est tant
mieux nous gagnons entre de et 3 mois de
vie supplémentaire chaque année
aujourd'hui à il y a un accord total sur
l'allongement sur le le changement pense
alors il y a un débat est-ce qu'il faut
que ce soit 63 64 ans ou 65 là il y a un
débat moi je pense que dire tout de
suite 65 ans on a une démographie
meilleure que nos voisins tant qu'à
faire au moins que ce soit un avantage
ça nous coûte suffisamment d'un côté
parce qu'on a une politique familiale
faut pas non plus que ça coûte de tous
les côtés donc si c'est une force jouons
dessus moi je pense que faut pas aller
sur la symbolique si on peut dire
progressivement d'ici 2000
enfin au-delà 2025 2030 il faut arriver
à 63 64 ans allons-y mais c'est surtout
sur la durée de cotisation ù il faut
dire attendez c'est pas raisonnable de
dire on ne va gagner qu'un an de
cotisation en plus de en 10 ans c'est
pas possible si on veut dire 63 ou 64
ans alors très bien n'allons pas 65 mais
accroissons la durée de cotisation plus
rapidement et puis trouvons des
solutions sur la pénibilité bien sûr sur
les gens qui ont commencé très tôt bien
sû mais en même temps il faut bien un
équilibre moi je ve vous dire cette loi
sur les
retraites c'est rien et dans 3 ans je
vous garantis gauche droite au pouvoir
il faudra un nouveau
texte date exactement pour finir vous
connaissez l'Élysée oui un petit peu on
vous y ène c'est le plus de Al bon si
vous m'y amenez pas pour
2017 alors en mai dernier sortait sur
vos écrans le film Le Pouvoir un
documentaire sur la plongée au cœur de
l'Élysée avec un homme principal
évidemment François Hollande en prime la
sortie du dvd et des bonus c'est Simon
Barbar qui vous explique tout
ça on avait quitté François Hollande sur
les marches de l'Élysée dans le
documentaire le pouvoir de Pierre Favier
et Patrick Rotman sortis en salle en mai
dernier le film est disponible en DVD ce
mois-ci avec en supplément une deuxième
version intitulée à l'Élysée
la intéale discours à saborateurs moi ce
que je vous demande c'est d'avoir des
notes qui fassent une
page de pages au maximum il faut que
tout soit résumé tout soit concentré en
une page ou deux et qui ne doivent pas
être des pages où on explique c'est des
pages qui préparent à la décision à la
manière d'un que saisje que l'on
pourrait croire destiné aux élèves de
l'énin le film à l'Élysée donne cette
fois-ci la parole au proche conseiller
de François Holande on prend également
l'agenda parlementaire puisque c'est lui
qui structure la vie politique de la
France les différents projets de loi on
prend tout ça et à partir de tout ça on
essaie d'organiser quand on peut un un
calendrier sur 3 4 5 et je vous dis si
possible jusqu'au un semestre souvent
technique parfois rébarbatif l'exercice
du pouvoir ôté de toute référence
politique nous laisse sur notre fin la
description de la sphère élyséenne
devient alors contemplative voire
superfici ciel les dorures du palais les
salons feutrés et les huissiers
méticuleux laissent une impression
d'isuette une illustration de
l'isolement du pouvoir que François
Hollande essaie de tempérer dans
l'entretien inédit moi j'accepte que les
Français me me parlent librement parfois
me demande une photo un autographe je
laisse finalement libre aussi les
Français d'aller jusqu'à moi pour
l'instant ils le font
pacifiquement on verra dans quelques
semaines
malgré les 8 mois passés dans les
couloirs du palais et les 50 jours de
tournage cette version complète des
coulisses du pouvoir reste plus proche
d'une journée du patrimoine à l'Élysée
que du scoop
médiatique verdict rogerti vous avez vu
le documentaire vousz pensé
rien je trouve que
sincèrement ou oui d'accord mais non
mais si c'est une visite historique
patrimoniale très bien mais d'abord
l'exercice du pouvoir il se fait pas
devant les caméras de télé donc toutes C
union filmée c'est du pipo intégral
chacun sait qu'il doit pas dépasser d'un
millimère ce qu'il doit dire bon donc
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe la
décision elle se prend à quelques-uns
elle se prend souvent au téléphone elle
se prend souvent dans un contact direct
avec le président ou avec le directeur
de cabinet ou avec le secrétaire général
vous vous n'avez pas tout ce cinéma avec
40 types qui viennent faire des notes
d'une page ENF c'est rigolo mais c'est
absurde deuxème élément voir le
président de la République actuelle dire
oh ben les Français moi je veux bien
qu'il fasse une photo avec moi d'abord
il y a de moins à moins de monde qui en
veut et deuxième élément ils viennent
vers moi pour le moment pacifiquement
heureusement qu'il dit pour le moment
enfin bon qu'est-ce que je vous dis
diser ça isole ou pas oui complètement
vous savez quand en en 2006 pendant la
campagne présidentielle Nicolas Sarkozi
me dit rejet j'ai une excellente idée il
faut en finir avec les isolements des
ministres du pouvoir et cetera on va
faire deux tours il y aura une tour pour
l'exécutif on mettra tous les ministère
et tout en haut on mettra le président
de la République comme ça on se verra
tous tous les jours et puis de l'autre
côté on fera une tour pour le Parlement
et on mais à côté l'un de l'autre comme
ça tous les pouvoirs seront regroupés et
les gens seront pas isolés c'est
infisable parce que les gens aiment les
palais et tout et puis puis pour
recevoir les étrangers tout c'est mieux
mais d'un autre côté ça avait cette
espèce de volonté de dire il faut sortir
de ça et c'est vrai que le pouvoir les
palais nationaux c'est bien par rapport
à l'image mais ça isole ça isole et bien
on va terminer sur cette action merci
beaucoup Roger carucci d'avoir été notre
invité restez sur les Chaîne
parlementaire à la semaine prochaine au
revoir au
revoir